every once in a while a revolutionary
product comes along that changes
everything today Apple is going to
reinvent the phone here it is why in the
world would Apple Computer want to jump
into the handset market with so much
competition we use all the handsets out
there it's really frustrating it's a
category that that needs to be
reinvented with over 2 billion units
sold the iPhone is the most influential
product of all time it created the
modern smartphone and turned the device
into an instant gateway to the world
everything you desire in the palm of
your hand it changed everything but
where did it come from if it wasn't a
sudden idea from Steve Jobs who actually
came up with the idea who are the people
that built it and what are their stories
with the most recent release of the
iPhone it's easy for many people to
forget just how revolutionary it once
was today we're gonna see how it all
began and how the pressure of doing the
impossible cost some people their
marriage and their health this video
will include my exclusive interview at
kenka gender one of the pioneers of the
original iPhone he worked directly with
Steve Jobs on the project this is the
secret history of the iPhone
you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
[Music]
to begin our story we have to go back to
the early 2000 at this time
human-computer interaction was a mess
before smart devices manipulating
digital objects was a chore in the early
2000s zooming in on an image usually
meant clicking on a menu selecting the
zoom option and then selecting the
amount you wanted to zoom in by how we
zoom in on an image today couldn't be
more different we can simply pinch a
screen and manipulate it with our
fingers back then such interactions
weren't obvious and only became possible
with touchscreens touchscreens existed
back then but they were predominantly
resistive touch that's the kind of
screen where you have to use a lot of
force to touch think ATM screens or
information screens at train stations
and airports on smaller screens
resistive touch is inexact and
frustrating in the 90s Apple tried to
use resistive touch in a device called
the Newton but it failed before even
dreaming of a device like the iPhone
this was the first problem that had to
be solved by 2007 the world was looking
for a new way to approach the mobile
phone they just needed a company to be
in the right place at the right time
with the right product he may be
surprised to find out that the first
seeds of the iPhone came not from Apple
but from a small company in Delaware
called finger works founded in 1998 by
Wayne Westerman finger works had figured
out how to use a different type of
technology effectively it was called
capacitive multi-touch it was fast
responsive precise and most importantly
smart enough to recognize multiple
fingers and what they were trying to do
I reached out to Wayne for an interview
but unfortunately after his company was
bought by Apple in 2005 he was whisked
away and sworn to secrecy
he couldn't give me any interviews about
his work in the early 2000s finger works
released a trackpad called the ire
gesture it helped people with wrist
injuries to easily use a computer
without aggravating their injury Wayne
westerman the founder of finger works
had suffered from a wrist condition
himself sometimes he couldn't tie more
than a page without his wrist
instead of despairing this condition
motivated him to innovate new solutions
for his university research paper and
this resulted in the finger works
technology Wayne even wrote a simple AI
program to help the system understand
the differences between accidental and
intentional touches when gestures were
performed the pet would interpret them
and turn the movements into computer
shortcuts like copy paste and scroll
Wayne Westerman and finger works would
play a critical role in the development
of the iPhone he is Ken Kashi anda to
talk about it a bit more my name is Ken
cash Enda and for many years I worked at
Apple from 2001 until 2017 in 2005 I was
asked to join the iPhone project I had
very good experience working with Wayne
but back at the beginning he had a
company called finger works which is an
independent company which Apple bought
apart for the technology and part to get
him because he was so talented
early on Steve Jobs hated the idea of
Apple making the phone he was concerned
about a lack of focus in the company the
precise issue that he'd solved on his
return to Apple in 1997 Steve Jobs
believed that a phone would only serve a
niche gink market cell phones at the
time were not the easiest to use so you
can understand why it wouldn't have
seemed bright for a trendy company like
Apple to get into this market as we all
know this sentiment would later change
[Music]
meanwhile within Apple a group of
engineers and software designers would
meet weekly and what used to be a user
testing room there were all from
different departments but united by
curiosity and imagination they realized
that the web and digital revolution was
bringing richer and ever more complex
media to computers they realized that
clicking and typing may not be the best
way to navigate this new future what if
there was a more fluid way to interact
with content with this idea that would
start an informal human-computer
interaction group within Apple their
goal was to improve our interaction to a
technology one day in 2002 an Apple
employee by the name of Tina Huang
brought a finger works device to work
due to a wrist injury it was a black
rectangular pad that allowed the
seamless execution of complicated
computer tasks by just the use of her
fingers
the finger works touchpad was seen by
some curious Apple human interaction
employees and they use a testing room
because they're already thinking of new
ways to interact with technology to them
multi-touch interaction was an
interesting prospect inspired they
whipped up a demo to show Apple's
marketing department using the
multi-touch gesture pad and a projector
they displayed an interactive image of
Mac OS the idea was that you could use
finger based gestures on the pad to
manipulate elements of the desktop
software the demo was met with minimal
enthusiasm from the marketing team they
just didn't see a need for it and how
could they there was no product that
would really need it unfazed the
interaction group continued to have
weekly meetings to discuss the
possibilities johnny if' who was one of
the weekly members of the informal group
had also shown Steve Jobs the concept
initially Jobs rejected it he remarked
that would only be good for quote
reading something on a toilet in quote
Johnny I EV being of a sensitive nature
took the comment personally and was hurt
by it after some further thought however
Jobs warmed up to the idea and the
project would be greenlit but it became
riddled with problems and was ultimately
shut down
July of 2004 Steve Jobs had a surgery to
remove a tumor in his pancreas the
realization that he might have a limited
time on this planet helped accelerate
the timetable of what needed to be done
at Apple about a year ago I was
diagnosed with cancer I had a scan at
7:30 in the morning and it clearly
showed a tumor on my pancreas I didn't
even know what a pancreas was the
doctors told me this was almost
certainly a type of cancer that is
incurable and that I should expect to
live no longer than three to six months
I have looked in the mirror every
morning and asked myself if today were
the last day of my life would I want to
do what I am about to do today and
whenever the answer has been no for too
many days in a row I know I need to
change something your work is going to
fill a large part of your life and the
only way to be truly satisfied is to do
what you believe is great work and the
only way to do great work is to love
what you do if you haven't found it yet
keep looking and don't settle as with
all matters of the heart you'll know
when you find it
around this time Tony Fadell who led the
successful iPod division suggested two
jobs that it would be a good idea to put
Wi-Fi in an iPod while Jobs thought
about it Tony and his small team would
get to work on a new iPod a PDA hybrid
prototype the result was a disaster
imagine an iPod with modified software
allowing users to navigate the web with
a click wheel Jobs hated it he
understood his that it worked but
thought it was a rubbish experience Jobs
told Tony to try another way
[Music]
in 2005 best sorting a programmer and UI
designer received a call from Steve Jobs
asking him to make a demo of a touch
interface of a scrolling list Steve now
wanted to do a touchscreen phone
demos were the way that Apple as a
company worked through creative concepts
and ideas to see what could be the next
product and then we would make demos and
something you could try out right away
and you know the thing is these first
demos and prototypes are never any good
you know you think that there is going
to be some genius aha moment but it
never worked like that well hopefully
there's some little kernel in there
there's some aspect of it that's
stronger than other aspects of it and so
you you go and look for those strong
parts natural world uses natural
selection generation after generation
improving and improving in technology we
have creative selection taking our ideas
and building up a product from these
humble beginnings it's a long iterative
evolutionary process while ording was
making the contactless demo he noticed
that when scrolling the text image would
suddenly stop when he hit the bottom of
the screen because of this sudden
stopping of all the motion he thought
that his code had crashed after some
time ording noticed that he had in fact
reached the end of the list this gave
him an idea why not have the image
balanced so that there's some visual
feedback that lets you feel like you've
reached the end of the list and not like
it suddenly crashed this was the genesis
of the rubber banding effect on the
iPhone when Steve saw audience rubber
banding effect for the first time he
realized that a phone could indeed have
a touch interface while work on the
scrolling list demo was happening other
touchscreen projects were secretly going
on at Apple as well as cool as these
demos were there were no more than a
bunch of disjointed concepts some
pinching and zooming here a few widgets
there some notes and the calculator but
nothing with a unified structure
Steve wasn't impressed with the
disjointed array of demos didn't seem
like those a product to sell in early
2005 Jobs gave the team two weeks to
create something great and it had to be
great or else a small team at Apple
spent two sleepless weeks trying to get
the company's first touchscreen phone
right they focused on the vision of a
phone and its function how do you make a
phone call on a touchscreen how do you
get from a calendar to web browsing
what's the logical flow of getting from
one application to another amazingly by
the end of the two-week period they had
something to show jobs the first time
Steve Jobs saw the prototype he didn't
jump for joy or exclaim anything he was
silent sitting back and he said show it
to me again he was in fact blown away
the project would be top secret with an
apple from that point forward around the
same time Apple would purchase finger
works bringing finger works his whole
team on board to try and help figure out
this new jackpot
so now Apple had two choices on how to
transform this technology into a product
one enlarged the already successful iPod
into a phone or to shrink Mac OS down
into a phone using finger works touch
technology nobody knew which would work
best so Steve let both ideas run the
iPod enlarging team was led by Tony
Fadell and the multi-touch Mac OS team
was led by Scott Forrestal force tools
team was seen as the underdogs
after all Tony Fadell had helped push
millions of iPod sales and was also
working on to Smash Hits the iPod Nano
and the iPod video
the battle had begun neither team was
allowed to know what each other was
doing in fact the hardware guys weren't
allowed to see any software and the
software guys weren't allowed to see any
hardware hardly anyone working on the
phone at Apple knew what the device was
going to look like until the keynote and
they weren't given a solid date for that
either during the stress some members
would quit and others would be fired at
one point Phil Schiller head of
marketing had had enough and thought
that both projects should be scrapped an
Apple phone with a blackberry style
keyboard seemed like the most sensible
option while these projects were going
top Apple executives convinced jobs that
something needed to be done about
encroaching the mp3 capable mobile phone
sales and quickly Jobs agreed to partner
with Motorola the coolest phone company
at the time with their thin razor phone
they would make an iTunes phone the idea
was people would try out iTunes on the
phone and then hopefully go off and buy
an iPod Apple would have no involvement
in the hardware only focusing on iTunes
integration the result was the Motorola
ROKR already outdated on release the
thing just sucked I go there and I just
resume my music right back to where it
was well I was supposed to resume my
music right back to where it was
I hit the wrong button but you can
resume your music right back to where it
was if you hit the right one the rocker
was so bad that it was soon being
returned at a rate of six times higher
than the industry average consumers for
expecting something big from Apple and
this wasn't it
after the Motorola failure Jobs returned
his attention back to the iPod phone
which was Tony fedele's team as it was
the safer option he still did leave the
touch Mac OS team led by Scott Forstall
to continue Tony's team tried a plethora
of designs one of which was similar to
an iPod video but with a phone mode if
you wanted music it would behave like a
regular iPod would touch controls for
play pause etc around a scroll wheel
when he needed to dial a number you
would switch it into phone mode and the
device would behave like a rotary phone
it wasn't perfect but Jobs still
insisted that the idea could work
nobody within Apple really knew what
this new device was the iPod team saw it
as another portable accessory like the
iPod so software wasn't important the
touch Mac OS team on the other hand saw
it as a fully fledged multi-touch
computer that fit in your hand Tony
Fadell and his team were certain that
this new phone should run a beefed-up
version of iPod software while Scott
Forstall and his team thought a shrunken
down version of Mac OS would be better
they theorized the mobile chip
technology had become powerful enough to
run a version of Mac OS it was juddery
at first but soon they managed to get
scrolling to work smoothly on a compact
version of Mac OS and from this point it
was decided that this would be the way
to go the shrunken down version of Mac
OS will become known as iOS and soon
Tony fedele's iPod phone idea would be
abandoned and all efforts would be
focused on iOS as the software began to
take place details have to be ironed out
how do you unlock this thing without
doing it by accident in your pocket
there's actually an interesting story to
have this was solved one day Freddy
answers a user interface designer within
Apple found the solution in the most
unlikely of places a toilet
one day Freddy was on a US domestic
flight and felt the need to relieve
himself he got up from his seat and went
to the toilet as Freddy lost the cubicle
door he happened to observe the locking
mechanism it was so simple
he just slide it to unlock and that's it
this concept little light bulb and the
result was the famous original slide to
unlock feature to test out this concept
an iPhone engineer later gave a
prototype to his three-year-old daughter
without hesitation she took her finger
slid and unlocked the phone if a
three-year-old to figure it out anyone
could
[Music]
meanwhile Johnny if' was beginning to
imagine what the hardware of this phone
could look like although later designs
would stray the first sketch from Johnny
if' was close to the final product he
was imagining an infinity pool quote
this pond where the display would
magically appear the rest of the device
had to get out of the way end quote
interestingly Johnny if' didn't want a
headphone jack in the original iPhone as
the project dragged on tempers rose
within the company due to secrecy
competition and the time pressure of the
project and it was no wonder everything
the teams were making was new
touchscreen technology was in his
infancy
the Apple engineers had to figure out
how to make a transparent version of
multi-touch mass-producible untested
custom chips had to be developed so
reception had to be worked out material
designs needed to be perfected basically
these teams which had never made a phone
before were now trying to make the most
ambitious device ever imagined imagine
how it must have been for the developers
- if any app they're working on crashed
it could have been because of virtually
a million things from their coding to
any one of the numerous experimental
hardware components by February of 2006
the team at Apple's didn't have a CPU
basically the brain of the device and
they was supposed to ship in a year they
decided to contract Samsung who they'd
partnered with previously for chips
within the iPod they are Samsung if they
had any powerful CPUs within certain
specifications and they did but the only
thing Samsung had was from a cable box
without telling Samsung about the iPhone
Apple said they would have need
modifications to this chip in just six
months this is much less than half the
usual development time for a new chip
and this would later cause problems by
early 2006 the iOS software was making
great progress but the keyboard still
sucked it was just too small to type on
and it failed in all of the demos
without a good keyboard the whole phone
wouldn't have worked realizing that the
entire project was in jeopardy
Scott Forstall paused all development of
applications on iOS and made everyone
focus on the keyboard issue everyone on
the team built keyboards for three
straight weeks when it came time to test
the results of their work they all still
were no good
there was only one engineer left to
demonstrate his keyboard it was Ken
Koshi endo nervously he set it up for
Scott to type on surprisingly it worked
and it was accurate the breakthrough was
made by using primitive AI to figure out
what was actually being typed
essentially a predictive text for
example if you were to type the letter T
there was a high chance you're going to
type the letter H next so the keyboard
would make the contact to region four
age larger without changing the
appearance of the button to the naked
eye Ken also had the foresight to use a
dictionary to power suggestions and
order correct it was clear to me after
the first couple of demos that's since
the screen was so small and since there
were no there was no tactile feedback on
the touchscreen that there was gonna
need to be some new element now my first
ideas were different shaped keys
different different ways of highlighting
the keys so that that you would just
move your fingers but that was that was
a failed idea that didn't work and so it
was the dictionary and software
assistance the notion that some code
running in the background looking at
your touches on the screen and trying to
figure out well what did you mean and so
combining that notion with the notion of
a dictionary and a lot of work and a lot
of experimentation gave you know printed
help to produce that that first result
of auto correction through for the first
iPhone
without Ken's ideas in that
high-pressure moment it's possible that
the iPhone wouldn't have made it off the
ground
[Music]
as always all coming down to the wire
for Apple disaster struck just three
months before the launch the custom CPU
chips from Samsung still had bugs that
cause the phones to crash would such
little time left on the clock
it was looking like a catastrophe wasn't
the making a stress built engineers
started working seven days a week and
some slept in their offices tempers
flared and employees shouted at each
other
one employee slammed the door so hard
out of frustration that the door handle
broke and she got trapped in her office
and had to be broken out with a baseball
bat it seemed like the iPhone which held
so much promise would be apple's
greatest disaster other aspects of the
iPhone were still being slapped on very
late in a product development cycle one
of its killer apps Google Maps was only
added as an afterthought on the hardware
side the original iPhone screen was
supposed to be plastic like the iPods
but the decision to use glass was made
one month after the launch
when the day of the keynote came on
january 9th 2007 none of the teams that
Apple knew exactly what the final iPhone
product would look like even though they
had worked on the project for years when
Steve Jobs took to the stage some things
were still incomplete
the iPhones buggy CPU is she hadn't been
properly solved yet only patched up for
the demo this meant that the phone could
crash at any time during the
presentation the Apple team held their
breath sweating as they sat and watched
Steve Jobs excitedly proclaimed and
we're calling it iPhone
it was mostly positive reaction from the
crowd but also some uncertain laughter
as some thought that Jobs was joking
about the name yet the demo was going
well the crowd was loving the smooth
scrolling and technological magic they
were witnessing there we go right there
and to unlock the phone I just take my
finger and slide it across all right I'm
gonna see that again okay sleep we
wanted something that you couldn't do by
accident your pocket and just slide it
across boom well how do I scroll through
my list of artists how do I do this I
just take my finger and I swirl
I mean that cool rubber banding up my
run off the edge we call it the pinch I
can bring them closer together and move
them further apart to make it bigger or
smaller and so I can just move them
further apart and stretch the image and
move it around
[Music]
as Tony Fadell leader of the iPod fine
team looked on Steve Jobs did something
pretty cool when showcasing to the crowd
had until a contact
he gleefully slid Fidel's name of the
iphone contacts list Tony's changed his
number I gotta update this anyway so I'm
gonna get rid of that and I could just
remove Tony boom there we go it's that
simple to edit these things he was
basically saying to Tony you're fired
it's got four still states that during
rehearsals of the presentation Steve
would always delete a random contact
never Tony's to the crowd it was just a
demonstration of how this phone made
everything fun and cool to use to those
working at Apple it was a message Tony
was in trouble in all of this there was
one glaring omission Wayne westerman on
lookers never knew his name and Wayne
wasn't even invited to the event but
without his multi-touch innovation there
would be no iPhone instead on stage
Steve Jobs stated that Apple had
invented multi-touch these events were a
summary of how the project had been for
most brutal the project was so hard in
the secret teams that are ruined
marriages and cost some workers their
health some employees worked every day
giving up their nights and weekends for
years at a time
iPhone engineer Andy Greenland speaks
quote the iPhone is the reason I'm
divorced it was probably professionally
the worst time in my life
he created a pressure cooker with a
bunch of really smart people with an
impossible deadline an impossible
mission and then you hear that the
future of the entire company is resting
on it there wasn't really any time to
kick your feet back on the desk and say
this is going to be really awesome one
day every time you turned around there
was some just imminent demise of the
program just lurking around the corner
it was especially hard on the married
guys there were a lot of
oblivious to the sacrifice the world was
electric with the buzz of the iPhone but
that new phone that yeah there right now
you see Brandis on tops everything here
we go
many people were anticipating the Mac
World Trade Show this week including
Andy and so far they've not been
disappointed the latest from this show
Apple CEO Steve Jobs unveiling what many
are calling a revolutionary new product
the iPhone you scroll lists like by
flicking like this and it's like a
roulette wheel stop like that it's just
so cool it's very clear to us that the
world's going mobile and we really
believe that that a device like this
which is you know an order of magnitude
more powerful than any mobile device or
any cell phone that's ever been created
and yet vastly easier to use is the
future when it was all said and done
keen fans lined up to get one you paid
five hundred dollars to secure a spot in
this line know just yeah come and sit
here what are you looking forward to
using your iPhone for um just the fact
that I could put all my music and
everything on there and it has a
touchscreen and I don't know I seen the
commercials it looks really cool for me
in 2007 after seeing Jobs's demo of
scrolling in gestures it made sense to
me that this was the perfect interface
for a small screen device the iPhone had
way more than a thousand times more
computing power than NASA did in 1969
when they put man on the moon yet it was
super easy to use with a full web
browsing experience to boot even
children could pick up an iPhone and
know what to do
capacitive multi-touch and gestures had
broken down the walls of human-computer
interaction the future had arrived
finally a computer in your pocket his
Apple software engineer Henry lamb
uruk's would put it quote we took a Mac
and we squished it into a little box
unquote other small touches like a
proximity sensor that turned the screen
off during a phone call so that it
didn't touch your face by accident and
an accelerometer that could sense if
you're holding the phone in portrait and
landscape made the whole package feel
like magic today it's just so easy to
forget just how much of a leap the
original iPhone was
what followed the iPhone was a complete
shift in how we thought about technology
now information in news was instant
we became totally connected all the time
though in the next decade this over
connectedness will cause some issues
[Music]
once the initial fanfare was over the
sales of the iPhone would be slowed it
would take the introduction of the App
Store in 2008 to really kick things off
again for Apple if it wasn't for the App
Store the iPhone could have just been
one of those devices that look cool and
was cool to use but never caught on for
an entire year after the iPhones launch
it could run a grand total of 16 apps
there's only one home screens worth of
apps and that was it and this isn't to
mention how limited the iPhone was
compared to some other devices out there
they had no multimedia messaging no
video camera no cut and paste no 3G and
the list goes on but that wasn't
important
Nokia blackberry and the rest of the
established phone companies had been
providing these features for many years
but the difference was for the first
time a device was now a changeable blank
canvas with no buttons since the device
could run apps on it the iPhone software
creators could make it whatever they
wanted it to be their creativity it was
only limited by their imagination and
the hardware capability today billions
of apps have been sold and the mobile
app space has become a new industry
companies like Nokia blackberry and pom
thought they knew the game but they
couldn't visualize the future they
thought things would never change and
before they realized it was too late to
prosper in this brave new world
Google was working on their own
BlackBerry's star phone with a hardware
keyboard but when they saw the iPhone
presentation they abandoned that idea
and went for full touchscreen the result
was the very first Android phone but
that's a story for another day
[Music]
as the years passed people became less
and less excited with each new release
of the iPhone maybe who have reached a
point where the devices are just so good
there's only incremental improvements we
can make I asked Ken what he thought of
Apple's direction and he stated that if
he was perfectly happy with Apple he
wouldn't have left in 2017 but he hopes
that they continue to innovate as we all
know Apple isn't the only game in town
anymore competition is much stronger
than ever before will may be the next
big thing from Apple is around the
corner but at this stage only time will
tell the story of the original iPhone is
one of great sacrifice risk and reward a
story that shaped technology and the
world as we know it it gave the average
person an interface to almost infinite
information and knowledge all in the
palm of their hand but sadly almost
nobody knows who invented these
technologies and what the cost was to
innovate such a device to finish off
we'll have some words from Ken I hope
that you all use technology and and
enjoy it and some of the products that
may be that I made are useful and
meaningful to you and bring you some joy
in your life if they do then I've done
my job
in all of this something has to be said
for Steve Jobs he may not have invented
the technologies and Ken told me he
wasn't the nicest person to work for
but Steve did care about making great
products and he would push people and
squeeze the very best out of them to
make these products happen and in that
vein without Steve there also would be
no iPhone if you've watched this video
to the end thank you I appreciate it I
hope you can now look down at your
iPhone all the other smart phones that
followed and appreciate how they came to
be if you want to see more video
documentaries from my book new thinking
there's a playlist below if you are new
here you can subscribe so you don't miss
out on more videos like this in the
future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cold fusion
are you thinking
[Music]